conférence de presse suivie de près par
notre envoyé spécialà qui china au james
andré bonjour james il a été longuement
question de la candidature de la
moldavie à l'union européenne elle est
légitime a dit emmanuel macron oui
absolument emmanuel macron qui a dit que
dans son rôle de président de l'union
européenne avec la france et la
présidence tournante du conseil de
l'europe eh bien la france allait
effectivement
militez-vous palais demandé à ce qu'ils
aient une issue en tout cas aller
demander est ce que il est une réponse
positive est favorable pour cette
demande mais me grise dans la crau
également expliqué qu'il lui fallait
bâtir un consensus et qu'il fallait
emmener avec lui de le reste de leur
peine dans cette décision donc voilà
c'est décidé on conseil de l'europe qui
va venir dans les jours qui viennent en
tout cas l'iran première ministre en et
mitch et à cet avis est évidemment
extrêmement attendu sinaoui un autre
chef de l'état qui était vraiment ici
l'un pour souligner l'importance des
efforts qui ont été réalisés par la
moldavie notamment vis-à-vis des
réfugiés l'ukrainien qui sont tentés
mais aussi les efforts de cette
administration de maya angelou clichés
des réformes justes et courageuses et
frob ce pour faire avancer le pays on
n'est pas de droit la démocratie à
savoir qu'il ya des conventions s'il a
été signé aujourd'hui une convention
fiscale entre la france et à la moldavie
pour éviter la double imposition
ainsi également qu'un renforcement des
liens notamment culturels entre les pays
et puis il ya un près de 15 millions
d'euros qui va être développée très
rapidement pour la moldavie et sept sur
cette route vers la candidature il ya
peut-être un obstacle la situation en
transnistrie ce territoire tenu par les
séparatistes pro russes depuis 1992
avait posé la question à un james sur la
situation est ce que voilà ça peut
devenir un obstacle à l'intégration
européenne de la moldavie quelle a été
la réponse du chef de l'état
on lui demandait s'il y avait un risque
de déstabilisation les attentes des prix
elle a dit qu'ils avaient des accidents
en ce moment toutes les semaines mais
l'a clairement laissé entendre que
l'objectif de la moldavie pour l'instant
et d'éviter toute escalade qu'il était
en relation avec les autorités un de 7
le public reconnaît autoproclamé
séparatistes soutenus par les russes et
que l'objectif pour l'instant était
d'éviter justement que la situation ne
s'envenime quant à emmanuel macron eh
bien je lui demandais si c'était un
obstacle sur le chemin de l'intégration
bien emmanuel m'a conduit à expliquer
que streit injuste que la moldavie se
trouve dans une situation actuelle les
et dans ses ambitions européennes en
raison de cette situation entre anti cri
et il a donc dit que c'était quelque
chose qu'il faudrait régler un petit peu
plus loin sur le chemin puisque l'on se
rappelle un peu un processus très lent
intégration européenne mais que
maintenant il fallait arriver à étudier
cette demande de candidature en pour
l'instant mettant de côté la question
finalement de la transnistrie et que ce
serait quelque chose qui serait gérée
comme je le disais plus tard dans ce
processus d'intégration mercy james
andré pour ce compte rendu en direct de
chisinau pour france 24